[Music]
so this demo is about showing how cube
flow and cuteness together can make
machine learning really easy scalable
and portable so the demo is about the
operational efficiency that you gain by
adopting cumulus and cube film so the
sample use case we have taken here
instead of like predicting sentiments
associated with reviews and so here's a
very simple web app right like let's go
let's go or some of the reviews that our
sample reviews that are listed here
first one says it's a typical McDonald's
for those typical employees their
typical everything is like typical so
there's really not nothing positive
about this review and so we would expect
it to be a negative review right you
don't want to highlight it in your
restaurant website as one of the premier
reviews and the second one here it's it
says it's good and the service is good
overall they do a good job so this seems
to be a pretty positive review so we
should only be highlighting that whereas
on the right side here it says really
excited to hear of this Western coming
to Toronto and so on so on service here
is not great so it's it's not a review
that you want highlight so it's probably
a negative review so what would you
expect let's say you throw this task at
your engineer and then your engineer
just builds something some some back-end
system to to classify them as positive
and negative let's see what the
engineers build turns out what the
engineer has built lessons doesn't meet
what the humans expect well like it's
it's literally classifying them
incorrectly let's go look at the code
that the engineer has used hmm this is
not good cold it's like it's like really
it's really dumb cold like I don't know
how that got checked in but any case
it's there so now let's go improve
weather let's go fix that
so this is where machine learning comes
to the rescue there's there's quite a
few machine learning models that you can
use to solve these sort of language
that pencil answer happens to be one
really popular model that can be used
for lots of different applications like
language modeling sentiment analysis
summarization and so on
wait and so sentiment analysis is one
application for this model so what we're
gonna do now is that we're gonna use cue
clove
you're gonna use the stencil denser
pre-existing model and we're going to
operationalize that we're going to train
that model using data a public data
that's provided by Yale and then what
we're going to do is when we are going
to deploy that model to a cumulus
cluster and then see if I can improve
this vibha to become smarter and and
make the right kind of predictions so at
this point I'm going to switch to my
terminal here I'm going to run the demo
so the first stage of the demo is that
I'm going to switch to mini cube then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
deploy deploy cue flow to my local mini
cube plus Q plug comes prepackaged with
a few components I'm going to show you
like what components exists in there and
you're also going to see that Q flow
abstracts out a lot of different cumulus
constructs that you have to put together
in order to build applications that data
sciences and mist ml practitioners can
consume they find it really hard to
consume cumulus directly so Q flow sort
of acts as a glue between the apps that
data scientists like and on the
infrastructure efficiency that cumulus
provides you
so I'm switching to my local mini cube
context here the next thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to deploy cube
flow locally so it's as simple as
running one simple command then the next
thing is I'm going to show duple and
notebooks so this is part of cube clover
you have Jupiler notebooks that are
built-in so you can go ahead and like
login and can create your own notebooks
there are many free cans images you can
choose different CPU in choose different
memory and then you can also choose GPUs
if you happen to have it but mini cube
doesn't support it yet so it probably
can't not use GPUs locally here but you
get a you get a pretty good set of
configuration that you can bring your
own images so what this provides you is
it provides you a local notebook
environment through which you can
iterate locally and build models
interactively locally but you're not
going to use notebooks now instead what
we're going to do is you're going to go
back and you're going to continue
training our model using command line
and and specifically what we're going to
do is we're going to use a TF job
operator that's packaged as part of cube
flow the TF job operator lets you do
distributor training and single load
training in a really easy portable way
so similar to how you define a
deployment or a job in cumulus you can
make an you can define tensorflow job
using the TF job operator and in the
tensorflow job what it does this takes
your tensorflow application packages
containers and sets up the runtime
environment that tensorflow needs in
order to make it work in a distributed
setting and in the local setting and
abstracts all of that so I'm going to
configure my tensorflow
model to to run locally I've set the
data to be available as locally and I've
set local training to be true and the
model is now deployed I'm going to check
if the if the training jobs are running
they seem to be running
and the next thing is I'm going to check
if the model is actually running by
looking at the logs okay looks like the
model is running but I'm gonna stop here
with local training because it's going
to take a long time it's probably gonna
take take a couple of days for local
training to complete but the point of
training locally is not to it's not to
build a model but it's rather to just
make sure that my model works as soon as
I know my model works I have the cloud
to the rescue right now I can switch to
the cloud and use Elastic Compute there
and that's what we're going to do next
and you're going to use the same cue
flow framework to do that so I'm going
to switch to a GK cluster and I'm going
to show you the GK cluster that I have
pre provision so here is a GK cluster
this cluster has GPUs and TPU is already
attached so a pre pro Shanda it's very
easy to provision gke
clusters with GPUs and GPUs it's like
literally running to commands and you
get like drivers and everything
pre-installed so I have like GPUs
attached here and GPUs are available
from all nodes and I also like pre pro
and a TPU here and the TPU is running
tensorflow
version 1.7 so the next thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to go back to
my terminal and I'm going to switch
context and switch to this GK cluster
and I'm going to deploy queue flow to
gke and once I've deployed queue flow
then I'm going to deploy my model to GK
so here we're deploying cue Florida GK
the next step is let me deploy the model
so I have to change the model parameters
such that it can run in the cloud of
enable GPUs for the cloud and I also
like enable set the data directory to be
on GCS and I have also disabled local
training so once the model is deployed
next off like in addition to GPUs you
can also use in Google cloud and now I'm
going to use I'm going to deploy the
same model but this time with TPS so
here you go like I've configured deep
use a few parameters to make the model
pointer a TPU and the models are not
deployed on GPUs as well now we're going
to wait for the paths to be running so
I'm going to switch to the gke UI and
I'm going to filter on my demo namespace
and once I felt that the I'm going to
check whether my training pods are
running so turns out my trained training
pots are running you see here that you
have a distributed cluster running so
you have two workers and a master and a
parameter server these are tens flow
concepts don't worry about it if you
don't know it and there's also TPU
training job that's running so if I go
into the TPU training job
if we're going to the DPO training job
then you would know that the TPO
training job is running and then there's
the GPU job here and then the GPU job is
running and you can see here that GPU
memory and GPU duty cycle are also being
shown here for you and the part is
running and you can go in here and you
can see the logs the training is
actually going on already and it's it's
saving checkpoints and so on so as we go
back then
okay so training is going on where
training is going to take quite a while
what can we do meanwhile so in addition
to that we also get tens abode I forgot
to mention this
you get tens abode that's going to help
you track the progress of your training
both locally and in the cloud I what I
have done here is like I'm showing you
tents about graphs that based on free
training models I ran through training
and this is what you would see so what
you see here is the GPUs you see about
training rate of about like three
roughly like 2.5 steps per second and
then in the case of TP use if you scroll
down you see like a much higher learning
rate and so this is to give you a rough
idea of like what sort of hardware you
might use and in any case like cubed s
and Q flow can I can work with both of
them so now now that we have gone
through the training process and now
that training is done the next office we
can't get training to complete and so
what we're going to do now is like we're
going to take a pre trained model and
deploy it to the same GK cluster and
then we're going to see if the if a
restaurant sentiment analysis UI can
perform better
I'm going to go ahead and deploy a
pre-trained model locally as I'm sorry
to my GK cluster and once that model is
deployed now I can go back and see if
the model is running so I'm going to
refresh and
my model is running it's the pods are
running so let's switch back to my UI so
I have the UI here it did with like
local classification it did not do well
as we would expect it so now let's see
if it does the with the machine learning
model yeah it does well like it's it's
classifying the first and the third
review correctly as being negative and
it's classifying the second review as
being positive so this should this demo
should have shown you how the overall
pipeline for for machine learning can be
simplified with cube flow and cube
renders together where your
infrastructure concerns and like
application packaging concerns are taken
care of for you
and you focus on building great machine
learning packages that are reusable and
making like apply machine learning
really really easy for the rest of the
world thank you